illustrous is unashamed in her ambition
to usher in a new era of fossil fuel
exploration and extraction in the UK
lifting the moratorium on fracking and
accompanying with that with an intention
to issue some 100 new licenses for oil
and gas drilling in the North Sea but
it's really the fracking side of things
that's caught people's attention
it is trust in her government saying
over and over again
Russia's invasion of Ukraine is driving
an energy security crisis and that's
what we're focused on that's why we need
more domestic sources of fossil fuels
and so they've reconsidered fracking but
critics are saying
um that we don't know very much about
what's down in the Shale reserves under
the ground in the UK and we won't know
about how much gas is recoverable until
the drilling happens the government has
said that fracking won't happen without
local support we still don't have any
detail on how that local support or not
is going to be established and I think
the central issue really for big
community in particular is that the risk
of seismicity when it comes to fracking
causing earthquakes hasn't gone away and
the government's just published a review
conducted by the British Geological
Survey which underpins its new approach
to fracking in which the scientists
there say that monitoring and predicting
seismic activity remains a challenge but
the interesting thing though although
the science hasn't changed you're
absolutely right that the appetite for
risk has and so Jacob rees-mogg the
business secretary has said that he is
going to look at expanding the
thresholds within which the fracking
industry has to work essentially
potentially allowing them more room to
create earthquake Quakes in the pursuit
of shale gas now anti-fracking
campaigners have already said that it's
unacceptable that communities should be
asked to tolerate more risk in the
pursuit of more fossil fuels